اذا مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
لمتابعه تداعيات الزلزالين الذين ضرب
ولايه التركيه وشعر بهما سكان دول سوريا
لبنان فلسطين والاردن وصولا الى مصر طبعا
اضرار وطالت منطقه شمال غرب سوريا الزلزال
اول ضرب مدينه انطاكيا بقوه
6.4 والثاني سمندر الساحليه في ولايه
هاتاي بقوه
5.8 اللافت اليوم كان حاله الهلع الكبيره
التي اصيب بها سكان المناطق التي طالها
الزلزال والتي دفعت البعض الى القفز من
النوافذ وتسببت في حاله من الفوضى
والتدافع ما تسبب في مقتل اربعه اشخاص في
كل من حلب وطرطوس وحمام واصابه نحو 500
في سوريا شمال غرب سوريا حسب المرصد الس
لحقوق الانسان بسبب التدافع هو ايضا بسبب
انهيار بعض المباني اما في تركيا فكانت
الحصيله ثلاثه قتله ونحو 200 وثلاثه عشر
جريح وتم تسجيل انهيار عدد من المباني في
مدينه انطاكيا مركز ولايه
طبعا الزلزالان تسبب باضرار في البنى
التحتيه وحدثت تشققات
وتصدعات في الجسور والطرق خصوصا في
انطاكيا مركز زلزال الاول والاقوى السكان
طبعا غادروا مبانيهم بعد حاله الرعب التي
اصيب بها الكثيرون ورفضوا العوده لمنازلهم
في الاثناء اكد وزير الداخليه التركي ان
فرق الانقاذ تعمل على انتشال العليقين تحت
الانقاب من المباني التي تهدمت
الله
حاضر
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا فقط نشير الى بعض المعلومات
المتعلقه
بالزلزالين مركز رصد الزلازل الاوروبيه
المتوسطي قال بان مركز الزلزال كان على
عمق كيلومترين وكاله الانظار نقلت عن نائب
الرئيس التركي قوله بان ثمانيه اشخاص
كانوا اصيبوا بجروح
كبيره عقب الزلزالين واكد مقتل ثلاثه منهم
طبعا عدد الجرحى في تركيا حتى الان
2003 عشر هناك انباء عن وجود اشخاص عالقين
تحت الانقاض واكد
نائب رئيس التركي ووزير الداخليه كذا بانه
الجهود الان
مصابه على انقاذ اولئك العالقين تحت
المباني نائب الرئيس التركي ناشد ايضا
جميع المواطنين عدم التوجه او الدخول الى
المباني في المدن المتضرره من الزلزال
هناك من المباني الايله للسقوط والتي تسبب
الزلزال السادس من فبراير باحداث الصدوع
بها بعضها انهار وبعدها ايه للسقوط طبعا
السكان بسبب حاله الفزع الشديد التي اصيب
بها الكثيرون غادروا منازلهم وبقيوا في
الشوارع في هذه المناطق على كل حال ينضم
الينا حسام زليط ومدير مركز خربه الجوز من
الدفاع المدني في ادلب ليطلعنا على رد فعل
الدفاع المدني على هذا الزلزال وايضا ابرز
مرصدوه من تداعيات واضرار سيد حسام كيف
يبدو المشهد لديكم الان
سيد حسام تسمعني
طيب يبدو ان الاستاذ حسام غير جاهز معي
يتحول الى موفد العربيه محمود شكر من
محمود الى اي مدى بدا الناس يستوعبون ما
حدث بايديان وردت فعلهم بعد مرور ساعات
على الزلزالين الجديدين كيف تفاعلت سكان
ايديمان معها
بطبيعه الحال بمساله بسيطه وسهله هي عمليه
شد اعصاب لانهم اعتقدوا ايقنوا ان هذه
الارتدادات او هذه
هذه
الزلازل الجديده اذا صح التعبير لان الذي
حصل مساء اليوم هو زلزال وليس هزه
ارتداديه هم اقتنعوا واعتقدوا الى ان
الافضل لهم ان ياخذوا الاجراءات المطلوبه
التي تطالب بها السلطات المحليه المحليه
وتحديدا اداره الكوارث ولكن لاكم معك
هادئا على توصيف هذا الواقع وايضا توصيف
الحقيقه الى ان التداعيات السلبيه لهذا
الزلزال هي تختلف عما جرى في الفترات
الماضيه اقله الى ان جل الناس في هذه
المدينه او في هذه الولايه بالاضافه ايضا
الى الولايات الاخرى هي خارج البنايات
وخارج الابنيه الاسمنتيه
بطبيعه الحال هي لم تعد الى هذه البنايات
ومنهم من عاد في اليومين الماضيين لانه
السماح بدا بالتوازن
اسمح لي اعذرني على المقاطعه ساعود لك
ستبقى معنا طوال هذه الساعه لكن اسمح لي
ان اتحول الان الى السيد حسام زليط ومدير
مركز خربه الجوز من الدفاع المدني في ادلب
سيد حسام تسمعني
سيد حسام لو تصف لنا المشهد الان في ادلب
وباقي المناطق في شمال غرب سوريا في عقاب
الزلزلين
تحياتي لك استاذ ابراهيم
طبعا
حاله هلا
وخديجه جدا جدا المدنيين نتيجه تاثيرهم
بالزلزال الذي حصل منذ عده ايام
وايضا والنتائج كارثيه حصلت على اهلنا في
الشمال وشمال غرب سوريا طبعا الزلزال
اللي حصل من من عده ساعات طبعا هذا الامر
حاله وفزع سليمه يعني كل الناس بتجهز الى
الشوارع
تركت بيوتر
واخذت اولاده
وتجلسهام بشوارع حاله خوف
حاله فزع كثير كثير صراحه يعني وهذا الشيء
يسبب ايضا حالات اغماء
واللي بعض
الاشخاص الى اي مدى يعني هذه الحالات
حالات الهلع والخوف يعني استجبتم لنذاءات
طلب الطوارئ من الدفاع المدني بسببها
باعتقادكم ان معظم حالات الاصابات
والوفيات حسب مرصد السوري هي بسبب التدافع
والهلع وحتى قفز الناس من النوافذ هل كان
لديكم او اي توصيات او نصائح للناس
للتعامل في ظل هذه الظروف
[موسيقى]
بجروح متفاوته وقصور انه في منها الجراء
سقوط حجاره عليهم وفي منها في بعض القفز
نتيجه الهلع والخوف عند الناس طبعا
وكان في حدا
ما يقارب 150 اصابه كان في واكثر من 45
حلب والحمد لله رب العالمين
بالنسبه للمباني التي تضررت هل لديكم اي
احصائيات على عدد المباني التي تهدمت او
المنازل هل هناك اي جهود لانقاذ عالقين
تحتها
طبعا الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني بعد
الاستجابه وبعد البحث والتاكد من عدم وجود
تحت الانقاب كان الاصابات مختلفه فقط ذكرت
لك بجروح متفاوته وكسور ثقوب حجار عليهم
او منخفز بالامن لم يسجل اي حالات
عالقين تحت الانقاذ طبعا الزلزال هو صراحه
يعني التاثير من الزلزال الماضي يعني
كمان غيرت قايل للسقوط كانت
بالزلزال اللي حصل
تم في انهيار لبعض الابنيه طبعا الغير
مقبوله
الجدران في طبعا المنازل لان ايضا في
مئزنتين في جامعين في مدينه جنديرس في
شمال حلب كمان
ونهارت شرفه والجدران في ابنيه في اغلب
مناطقوا حلب دون اصابات في هذه الزيارها
طب كيف يبدو المشهد الان يعني هل عاد
البعض الى منازلهم ام انه حاله الخوف
والهلع ما زالت تسود بين السكان ويخشون من
العوده خصوصا انه يعني بعد الزلزالين تم
تسجيل اكثر من عشر هزات ارتداديه
اللحظه يعني في بعض ما زال موجود في
الشوارع صراحه يعني
حاله هلا وخوف الاهالي يعني معظم الاهالي
وقت
سقوط
الزلزال السابق طبعا الناس تعيش في حاله
توتر نفسي صراحه
يعني
خلينا نقول انه عميس الاهالي صراحه يعني
مفهوم يعني
يعتبر انه منزله منزله او مكان سكنوا امن
رجع بشكل تدريجي ولكن
موجود في الشارع صراحه طيب شكرا جزيلا على
وجودك معنا حسام زليط ومدير مركز خربه
الجوز من الدفاع المدني في ادلب واعود الى
ضيفي من موفد العربيه محمود شكر محمود
اعذرني على المقاطعه تفضل باستكمال فكرتك
طبيعتك هي غير مسكونه من الناس لذلك الناس
تعودت على ان هذه هذه الهزه ثم هذه
الارتدادات هي ستتوقفهم سيتعاملون معها
بطريقه على حسب الارشادات لذلك في اليومين
الماضيين كان هنالك جو كبير من الخبراء في
اداره الكوارث التركيه او من اصحاب
الاختصاص او من المسعفين او من الذين
كانوا يقومون على مدى العشره ايام الماضيه
بعمليات الانقاذ للمواطنين الاتراك الى
انه اذا كانت هنالك هزه لا تذهب اطلاقا او
تخرج من الشقق لان اكثر الذين تم انتشال
جثثهم في الفترات الماضيه كانت هي في
الدور
في بنايات الادراج للبنيات وعليه من يريد
ان ياخذ عليه ان يذهب الى النقطه في
الغرفه او ياخذ عده احتياطات او اين
يستلقي تحت
طاوله من الخشب هذه في الايام العاديه او
في الظروف اذا كنا نتحدث عن انه يوجد
هنالك ناس ولكن هنا في المدينه وفي الاغلب
المدن الولايات التركيه في الجنوب التركي
الناس هي لم تعد حتى هذه الساعه الى
منازلها لذلك نتحدث عن ثلاثه حتى الساعه
من عدد الضحايا لربما عمليات القاضي انتهت
في ولايه
هاتاي وعن عدد من الجرحى الذين اصيبوا
بالحجاره او ايضا بعمليه التشقق التي حصلت
في بعض البنايات وكان هنالك من حجاره او
من زجاج او من غير ذلك بعد ذلك الامور هي
هادئه المفارقه الاساسيه الى انها اتت ست
درجات على عشره في حين الى انه الاف من
الهزات الارتداديه وصلت الى الاربعه
والخمسه في الفترات الماضيه وايضا
بالتوازي الجو اللوجستي والعسكري والامني
والاداري والطب للحكومه التركيه وللمنظمات
هي موجوده على الارض والقدره استيعابيه
للانقاذ على الصدمه الاولى سريعه جدا من
الجو الى الارض الى الاسعافات الى كل هذه
القضايا لذلك راينا هذه النتائج السلبيه
محصوره فقط بعدد قليل من الجرحى وبعدد
قليل من الضحايا شكرا على كل هذه الاحاطه
محمود شكر موفد العربيه كنت مع من اديمان
ونتحول الان الى محمد الاشقر مراسل
العربيه ينضم الينا من ريف سلقين بادلب
اهلا بك محمد كيف كيف يبدو المشهد لديك
اخر حصيله
للضحايا والاضرار
نعم يعني في الحقيقه لا تزال بعض الاهالي
المنتشرون في شارع الكورنيش في مدينه
سلقين خوفا من تكرار هذه الهزات وانهيار
بعض المباني طبعا الكثير منهم منازلهم
تصدعت وهناك من لا يزال منزله يعني مقاوما
ولكن نتيجه الخوف والهلع الذي اصابه من
الهزه الاخيره التي ضربت تركيا وشعر بها
معظم سكان شمال غرب سوريا طبعا بالنسبه
للاحصائيه الاخيره فبحسب الدفاع المدني
قالوا ان اكثر من 130 مدني في مناطق شمال
غربي سوريا
اصيبوا بحالات كسور وردود وحالات اغماء
وخوف وهلع نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
ليله امس طبعا هذه الاصابات اغلبها كانت
نتيجه الخوف والهلع هناك البعض من من سقطت
الحجاره نتيجه
طبعا هناك من اصيب نتيجه رمي نفسه من شرفه
منزلي
المباني المتضرره في عموما
فهناك مبنيين متصدعين من
الزلزال المدمر
المهارات بشكل كامل طبعا هذين غير ماهولين
بالسكان لذلك لم يسجل اي اصابات في مدينه
جنديرس وايضا سجل انهيار قبه هل السبب فقط
بانه يعني هذه المنازل يعني
كانت تدمرت في الزلزال السابق ام انه شده
هذا الزلزال كانت اقل وبالتالي تاثيرها
على المباني في شمال غرب سوريا كان اقل
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هذه الهزه هي يعني
شدتها اقل بكثير من الزلزال المدمر الذي
حدث في المره السابقه ولكن المباني التي
سجلت انهيارها تصدعت من الزلزال المدمر
الماضي وانهارت بفعل الهزه الاخيره للسقوط
اصلا
الى للسقوط وسقطت نتيجه هذه الهزه طبعا
ايضا سجل انهيار بعض المباني في القرى
المحاذيه لريف اللاذقيه وهنا اتحدث عن قرى
خربه الجوز وبيت صوفان والملاند
والحمزيه في ريف ادلب الغربي ايضا سجل
انهيار بعض المباني في هذه القرى اما
بالنسبه للمناطق الاخرى في عموم شمال غرب
سوريا فقد انهارت وبعض المباني بشكل جزئي
سجل انهيار بعض الجزء الجدران في
نتحدث عن انهيارات لكن هذه المباني التي
انهارت هل كانت اهله بالسكان هل كان فيها
اشخاص هل هناك اشخاص تحت الركام الان كيف
يتم التعامل مع هذا الموضوع والشق الثاني
من السؤال انه الذين خرجوا الى الشوارع
خصوصا في سلقين حيث ان هل عادوا الى
منازلهم من الخوف ما زال يتملكهم وبالتالي
يخشون من العوده اليها
للسقوط سكانها يعني لجاوا الى الى المراكز
الايواء المؤقته او حتى المخيمات المنشاه
سابقا او حتى المستحدثه لذلك لم تسجل اي
حالات
اصابات تحت الركام اي ان هذه المنازل
خاليه الى هذه اللحظه لم تردنا ايه انباء
عن وجود ضحايا تحت انقاذ هذه
المباني التي دمرت بفعل الهزه الاخيره اما
بالنسبه
لوضع الاهالي الذين لجاوا الى الشوارع فلا
يزال العديد من الاهالي يعني يفترشون
الطرقات تعني اتحدث هنا عما اشاهده وانا
في شارع الكورنيش في مدينه سلقين هناك
مئات الاهالي لا يزالون الى حد هذه اللحظه
في الشوارع هناك البعض من يعني عاد الى
منزله ولكن الاكثريه لا تزال في
الشوارع ربما خوفا على العائله خوفا على
الاطفال هناك العديد من الاطفال يعني
نلاحظ انهم لا هل هناك اي شخص يقدم لهم
مساعدات جهه تقدم الخيام تحاول ايواء
هؤلاء خصوصا ان درجات الحراره في الليل
منخفضه جدا في هذه المناطق
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هناك لاحظنا وجود
العديد من الفرق التطوعيه التي تحاول مد
يد المساعده لهؤلاء
الاهالي ولكن نقص الخيام ونقص مراكز
الايواء يعني دفعت يعني هذا العدد الهائل
ان يبقى الى حد هذه اللحظه في الشارع
خصوصا ان بعض هؤلاء العائلات يعني منازلهم
لم تتضرر ولكن الخوف والهلاعب دفعهم الى
النزول الى الشارع ولكن بشكل عام هنالك
العديد ممن تصدعت منازلهم لا يزالون الى
حد هذه اللحظه في الشارع بانتظار من يمد
لهم يد العون وينقلهم الى مراكز ايواء
مؤقته او حتى خيام يعني هل هذا هل نفهم من
كلامك محمد بان هؤلاء لا نيه لديهم للعوده
الى منازلهم بسبب الخوف وليس بسبب تصدعها
بفعل الزلزلين
نعم هناك هناك اتحدث عن البعض ولكن هناك
العديد من العائلات تصدعت منازلهم ولكن لا
يوجد لديهم ماوى هم ينتظرون مد يد العون
لهم ونقلهم الى مراكز ايواء مؤقته او حتى
مخيمات يعني في الحقيقه منطقه شمال غرب
سوريا في العموم تعاني من نقص حاد في
الخيام هناك مناشدات كثيره اطلقت من
المنطقه للاسراع
بادخال الخيام وتامين ماوى لالاف العائلات
الذين لا يؤمنون العوده الى منازلهم دعني
ان انقل لك الصوره التي حدثت معنا 10
اليوم في مدينه ارمناز وهي المدينه التي
نالت جزءا كبيرا من الدمار هنالك مدمر
بشكل جزئي عشرات العائلات لا تزال تسكن
منازلها وهي متصدعه لاحظنا ان
فرقا دخلت الى هذا الحي وكتبت على الحائط
يمنع الدخول المباني مهدده بالسقوط ولكن
نتيجه عدم وجود ماوى لتلك العائلات عادوا
الى منازلهم هنا لذلك اطلقت مناشدات من
اهالي هذا الحي ان يسرعوا بايجاد ماوى
هناك مناشدات يعني الى حد هذه اللحظه
الحديث الدائر هنا في عموم شمال غرب سوريا
التي يدور بين الاهالي عن احتماليه تكرار
هذا الزلزال هل ستتكرر هل ستشتد الهزات
الارتداديه مع الساعات القادمه هل سنشهد
المزيد من الدمار هذا هو السؤال الدائر
هنا عند عموم الاهالي في منطقه شمال غرب
سوريا يعني المناشدات حد هذه اللحظه تطلب
من المنطقه للاسراع في ايجاد الماوى لالاف
العائلات التي التي لا زالت سنعود
لاستكمال الحديث معك محمد الاشقر المراسل
العربيه كنت معنا من ريف سلقين بادلب لكن
اسمح لي ان اتابع تغطتنا هذه بعض الاخبار
ومناقشه عدد من الضيوف حيث الغت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه تحذيرها حول
امكانيه ارتفاع مستوى مياه البحر عقب
زلزله ولايتها جنوبي تركيا بعد تقييم
اجراء مرصد قنديلي للزلازل كتدبير احترازي
لابعاد السكان عن السواحل وتفادي خطر
ارتفاع مستوى البحر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وانضم الينا من اسطنبول للكاتب الصحفي
فيراس رضوان اوغلو اهلا بك سيد اغلب في
تغطيتنا للتداعيات هذين الزلزلين ربما
الناس انتبتهم حاله من الرعب والخوف جراء
هذان الزلزلين لكن المقاربه الحكوميه كانت
ربما اكثر سرعه بسبب وجودها ايضا على
الارض في هذه المناطق الى اي مدى ساهم
وجود الفرق والاستعداد الحكومي في التقليل
من اضرار هذين الزلزالين
نعم يعني هذا حقيقي ربما ايضا ان الزلزال
جاء في في منطقه قريبه من الزلزال او
زلزال الزلازل التي حصلت سابقا لو كان
الامر ربما معاكسا جاء باقصى الشارقه او
اقصى ربما كانت الكارثه ايضا كبيره لان
ايضا كل يعني
الطوارئ وللهلال الاحمر وكل هذه المنظمات
يعني هي مستنفره تماما في الجنوب هذا اظن
يعني كان ايضا يعني مساعدا في هذا السياق
لذلك لاحظ بسرعه كانت هناك التوجه بكل
الاماكن كانت كل المعدات كل الاجهزه كل
الطواف ممكن كانت كلها جاهزه وموجوده على
ارض الميدان يعني هذا كان واضحا جدا حتى
بسرعه كان يعني عدد الجرح الذي اعلنت عنه
غزاله الداخليه والوزير الداخليه وعننا عن
الوفيات اولا عدد لا يوجد
عن السيده وبعد ذلك حصل الى ثلاثه كان
هناك ايضا نقل على احدى القنوات عن اشخاص
كانوا
يحضرون بعض ادواتهم المنزليه فلما حصل
زلزال بقوا داخل الزلزال ويتم انقاذهم من
تلك من ذلك المنزل
حتى بعض الصور التي وردت ايضا عن تصدعات
هي ليست كبيره ولكنها عميقه يعني لا نعلم
لان بسبب ربما الليل لا يوجد اضاءه كامله
كان يعني الطريق مشقق تقريبا 30 الى 40 سم
والعمق لا نعلم مده العمق الى الى الى
الداخل هذا في في بعض الطرقات في انطاكيا
في ايضا مرسين او سمنداغ السويديه هناك
حتى بعض الفيديوهات لكن لم يذكر عنها كانت
هناك اضاءات متعدده هل هي انفجارات في
انابيب الغاز التي تمد تلك المناطق
يعني هذا كله
لاحقا فيما يتعلق بالخدمات يعني ما ان
نجحت الحكومه التركيه في استعاده خدمات
الغاز والكهرباء حتى عاد هذا الزلزالان
ليقطع
الخدمات عن السكان وبالتالي الى اي مدى
الان هذا ربما يمثل تحدي بالنسبه للحكومه
على صعيدين الاول التعامل مع تداعيات
الزلزالين والاستعداد ربما لزلازل اخرى
خصوصا انه الهزات الارتداديه لا تتوقف سته
الاف منذ السادس من فبراير واكثر من عشره
بعد الزلزالين اليوم
وايضا نسمعه من الاصدقاء هناك العمل يعني
حقيقه العمل الجبار قوي يعني لا يوجد توقف
هناك عمل نشيط جدا وهذا يعني يحسب للجميع
يعني سواء للبلديات او للحكومه
الاختلاف
يعني حسب الاحزاب طبعا اغلب المدن هي تنفع
لحزب العداله والتنميه سواء في البلديات
او في الحكومه يعني كتصويت عام بعضها مثل
الامطار مثلا او مرسين لكن العمل اظن حتى
الان هو يعني وفق المعطيات الاخيره العمل
جيد جدا لكن يوجد هناك بعض
النقصان في بعض الامور يعني الناس
المتواجده في الخيام الناس التي ما زالت
ليست بلا ماوى كافيه انك تظلها موجوده في
مراكز الايواء هذا اظن يعني
لم ينتهي بعد هذا الامر ربما ايضا هذا
الزلزال الذي حصل في الامس سيكون يعني
ايضا سيؤخر اظن بعض هذه
الامور طبعا هناك بعض الاشياء الشكاوي
التي تاتي بالنقص في بعض المواد بعض
الامور هذا ربما ياتي بي اشكال فرديه هذا
موجود لكن التحدي كبير في هذا السياق لا
نعلم كيفيه يعني
تغيير
هذا الزلزال الان ننتظر التقييم ربما
سنتحدث بعد قليل مع خبير زلازل ليطلعنا
على هذا الموضوع لكن اسمح لي ان اسالك
سؤال اخير انه موضوع حاله الرعب
والهلع التي اصابت الناس هناك الكثير من
حالات الاصابه التي سجلت بسبب حالات
التدافع وايضا السقوط والقفز من وبالتالي
بعد هذين الزلزالين الكثيرون ربما اصابتهم
حاله هلع تمنعهم من العوده لمنازلهم حتى
لو كانت غير اليه ايله للسقوط او متصدعه
وبالتالي هؤلاء بحاجه الى ان يتم تسكينهم
وهذا تحدي يضاف الى التحديات الموجوده
اصلا للحكومه التركيه كيف ستتعامل انقره
مع هذا المعطى الجديد
الموضوع حقيقه ليس بهذه السهوله فعلا هو
موضوع هو امر صعب هم حتى الان تم نقل من
حجز جميع
المنتجعات الفنادق
في مناطق الشمال الغربي من البحر من تركيا
وفي القريبه من بحر ايجا الى بحر المتوسط
داتشا مولا كثير هذه الناطق تم ربما
الاستعانه بهذا السياق وايضا حمله بيتي
بيتك التي انطلقها بشكل كبير لديه قدره
على استضافه عائله مثلا فليقم ذلك اضافه
الى الكثير ممن استطاعوا ينتقلوا الى
اقاربهم
في في مدن اخرى من اسطنبول طبعا في هذا
السياق لكن نحن نتكلم على ارقام صغيره
ليست ارقام كبيره هناك ما زالت ارقام
حقيقه متواجده لذلك ربما الاسراع في انشاء
على الاقل في بعض المناطق انشاء في
الابنيه
طبعا الامنيه التي ستكون معااتيه او
وكان ايضا الرئيس تكلم اليوم حول انهم
يريدون تغيير موقع الابنيه لن تكون على
ضفاف الانهار التي او الجداول التي تم
اغلاقها مثلا وانشاء الطرقات عليها هذا
كله يريد تغييره الى ابعد من ذلك على ربما
وربما يعني كان هناك حديث حتى بعض المدن
والقرى سيتم البناء في مناطق قريبه منها
وليس في نفس المكان على كل حال انا اشكرك
ربما نعود لك في سياق هذه الساعه لكن اسمح
لي ان اتحول الى السيد حسام او السيد
محمود القريوتي الخبير في الزلازل من عمان
اهلا بك سيد حسام او محمود بدايه لو
تعطينا
قراءتك لما حدث اليوم يعني هل
هذا النوع من الزلازل سجل تاريخيا قبل ذلك
يحدث زلزال مدمر ثم هزات ارتداديه على مدى
اسبوعين ثم يعود ويحدث زلزال ايضا يتسبب
بتدمير مباني ام انها حاله فريده وجديده
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير لك
وللمشاهدين
يعني يعني هذه السلوكيات او او الطبيعه
الزلزاليه يعني تعتاد عليها هذه المنطقه
والمناطق الجزريه بشكل عام يعني النشاط
الاول كان عباره عن ازمه كبيره وعاصفه
كبيره وعاده العواصف يعني حسب حجمها
وقوتها
عاصفه بهذا الحجم سوف تستمر كما يعني في
مداخلات سابقه لعده اسابيع ولربما عده
اشهر فبالتالي من الطبيعي ان يستحدث عن
عاصفه من الهزات الارتداديه
نعم بالاضافه للزلزال الرئيسي هو الزلزال
الرئيسي هو ما يتبعه من
الزلازل ارتداديه تسمى هذه عاصفه
يعني كما ذكرت تستمر ربما اسابيع وشرب حسب
حجم هذه العاصفه وبما ان هذه العاصفه من
النوع القوي والشديد جدا اعتقد راح تستمر
يعني اسابيع ولربما اشهر ما حصل ما حصل
قبل كم من ساعه في في مناطق انطاكيا وغرب
سوريا يعني لا شك ان هذا النشاط الزلزالي
له علاقه بالنشاط الذي حدث قبل اسبوعين
لكن حدث حقيقه على جزء اخر من الصدع حدث
حقيقه هذا على صدع ما يسمى القوس القبرصي
الذي يلتقي مع صدى
هذا القوس القبرصي الموجود في جنوب جزيره
قبرص
على شكل قوس باتجاه الشمال الشرقي ليلتقي
مع صدر الشرقي وايضا يرتقي مع صدى البحر
الميت التحويل الذي يمتد من خليج العقبه
الى جنوب تركيا
ان نتحدث عن موضوع الانتقال يعني هناك ما
تم تفسيره على انه كان هناك قوه كامله
تسببت في زلزال كهرمان مرعش والان الان
يحدث فيها تاي هل يمكن عندما يحدث زلزال
من هذا النوع ان تنتقل القوه الكامنه من
منطقه الى منطقه اخرى وتتسبب في زلزال في
تلك المنطقه
يعني هذا هذا النوع يسمى الهجره نعم
النشاط الزلزالي يهاجر المنطقه الى اخرى
طبعا يعني نحن نتحدث عن صفيحه عربيه تتحرك
الى الشمال واحدث التكسرات عنيفه في
المنطقه الشماليه هذا التحرك هذا التحرك
لا بد لا بد ان يكون هناك تغيرات على
اطراف الصفيحه في في عده مناطق من هذه
الصفيحه وما حدث فعلا قبل ساعات هو تغير
مفاجئ طبعا الذي احدث النشاط الذي ذكرنا
وهذا عباره عن زلزال رئيسي يتبع ايضا
توابع او زلازل في ارتداديه فبالتالي حدث
نشاط قبل اسبوعين الان حدث نشاط اخر في
مكان اخر في على طول هذا الصدع لا شك ان
لا هناك علاقه بينهما لكن يعني هذه عاصفه
وتلك عاصفه اخرى فبالتالي نعم ينتقل لنشاط
من مكان الى الى اخر حسب يعني تغيرات
وانتقال الطاقه الزلزاليه على طول او على
حدود هذه الصفيحه لا ادري دكتور محمود هل
من قبيل الصدفه بانه في السادس من فبراير
حدث زلزالان
يوم امس حدث ايضا زلزالان كبيران وهزات
ارتداديه هل من قبيل الصدفه ان يحدث هذا
الامر ام ان هذا السلوك الزلزالي معروف
لديكم ان يحدث الزلزال الاول ويلي زلزال
اقل قوه منه
اخي الكريم يعني العواصف الزلزاليه حقيقه
هي على ثلاثه انواع او ثلاثه اشكال منها
ما يحدث زلازل قليله العدد وقليله القوه
ثم ياتي زلزال كبير يسمى الرئيسي لهذه
العاصفه ثم يتبعه زلازل تابعه اقل منه
بالقوه وينتقل عددا هذا النوع الاول النوع
الثاني ياتي الزلزال الرئيسي مباشره
ولا ياتي زلزال زلازل قبله ياتي زلزال
الرئيسي ثم يتبعه زلازل ارتداديه حسب حجم
هذه
العاصفه النوع الثالث تبدا النشاط
الزلزالي في الحدوث شيئا فشيئا ويزداد
عددا وقوه لهذه الزلازل الى ان يصل الى حد
معين ثم يبدا بالتدريج العدد والقوه الى
ان تنتهي هذه العاصفه يعني هذه الثلاث
انواع من النشاط الزلزالي الذي يحدث عاده
في العواصف ما حدث في النشاط الاول هو
زلزال رئيسي ثم اتبعه يعني الزلازل اقل
الزلزال الرئيسي بقوه 6.4 كما نشاهد على
الشاشه ثم اتبعه الزلزال الاخر على ساحل
متوسط في سمندر بقوه فاصله ثمانيه كان
هناك تحذير من قبل السلطات بامكانيه حدوث
امواج تسونامي او ارتفاع المد ثم تم الغاء
هذا الامر هل يمكن ان يحدث هذا الامر اذا
ما حدث مركز الزلزال على الساحل ام انه
مرشح اكثر للحدوث عندما يحدث في عمق البحر
يعني في المنطقه التي حدث فيها النشاط
اعتقد مستبعد ان يكون هناك تسونامي او مد
بحري لسبب بسيط ان قالبيه الحركه او يعني
المتجه الرئيسي لهذه الحركه افقيه عاده
التسونامي او المد البحري يحدث على صدوع
الراسيه او العكسيه وليس على صدوع افقيه
وهذا طبعا ما يسبب اذا حدث على صدع راسي
او عكسي يسبب اندفاع شديد لكتل المياه
طبعا باتجاه الشواطئ وبعرف التنامي لكن
الحركه الحركه الافقيه لا يمكنها ان تفعل
ذلك فبالتالي
حقيقه مستبعد مستبعد جدا ان ان يكون هناك
اي اي تحركات للمد البحري لكن قد يكون
هناك بعض يعني ارتفعت القليل بسيطه لان
هناك متجه بسيطه وقليل بالاضافه
للمتجه الافقي قد يكون بسيط راسي لكن قد
يكون تاثيره ضعيف او او قليل بالنسبه
للاضرار التي يحدثها الزلزال على البنى
التحتيه
والجسور والسدود يعني وزير الزراعه التركي
قال بانه لا خطر على السدود فيها لماذا
تصمد السدود بينما تنهار المباني وتتشقق
السدود وتحدث ربما افلام واوديه في
المزارع
نعم يعني عاده اخي الكريم السدود يعني
يعطى اليها انتباه انتباه يعني فيما يخص
فيما يخص
مقاومه افعال الزلازل
وباعتقاده يتم بنائها على اشتراطات
ومعايير الهندسه الزلزاليه بحيث ان يتم
يعني مقاومه هذا النشاط الزلزالي لكن لكن
اذا بنيت السدود على الصدع مباشره اعتقد
هذا هذا لا يمكن ان يصمد اي سد في ذلك
الحركه لا يمكن لا يمكن ايقافها لكن اذا
لم يبنى على الصدع مباشره ويبنى على
معايير هندسيه واشتراطات الهندسيه في تلك
المناطق اعتقد انه سوف يتم يعني مقاومتها
لافعال تلك الزلازل لكن ما يحصل في
الابنيه
والمنشات الهندسيه الاخرى اعتقد يعني هناك
عده عوامل تؤ على الابنيه منها هل التزمت
هذه الابنيه والمشاريع المعايير الهندسيه
الشيء الاخر ما هو الطبيعه الجيولوجيه
التي بنيت عليها تلك المنشات فعاده كلما
كانت الطبيعه الجيولوجيه متفككه وتربه
يعني رخوه حقيقه هذا يزيد في الدمار ويزيد
في الخراب لتلك الابنيه واعتقد يعني كما
شاهدنا هناك كثير من الابنيه هدمت بسبب
الطبيعه الجيولوجيه فبعضها كما شاهدت اخي
الكريم بعض الابنيه لم يحصل لها دمار لكن
اصبح لها ميلان في اتجاهات معينه هذا دليل
على ان بنيت على التي نعم ليست قويه
وبالتالي مالات ربما لا تبنى على صخور
وانما على منطقه ترابيه اشرت لنقطه مهمه
جدا انه عند بناء الجسور يؤخذ الموقع بعين
الاعتبار حسب الان الانباء هناك عن توجه
في تركيا الى اعاده
نقل المباني في مناطق اخرى السؤال انه
لماذا لم يتم اعتبار هذا الامر في السابق
خصوصا ان تركيا منطقه زلازل ومعروف بان
هذه المناطق هي مناطق صدوع وبالتالي مرشحه
لان يحدث فيها زلزال وان تسقط هذه المباني
هذه الملاحظه اخي الكريم يعني انا لاحظتها
على مدينه مدينه انطاكيا يعني انطاكيا
للاسف يعني يعني بنيت على الصدع الرئيسي
او قريب من الصدى الرئيسي وهذا اعتقد يعني
يعتقد يعني يعني
مجازفه كبيره في الابنيه
يعني يجب يجب وليس يفضل فقط بل يجب
الابتعاد عن الصدوع النشطه وجعلها مناطق
مفتوحه اما للزراعه او لاماكن اماكن
مفتوحه لاستخدام لاستخدامات المعينه في
ذلك لكن التجمعات السكانيه اعتقد يجب ان
تبنى بعيدا عن هذه الصدوع واخي الكريم
يعني تحديد الصدوع ليس بالمهمه الصعبه
فغالبيتها تكون على يعني ظاهره ظاهره على
الصدع على السطح وايضا يمكن معرفتها
باستخدام طرق الجزئيه المعروفه في ذلك
معنى ذلك تحديد الصدوع بالامر الصعب فيمكن
تحديد تلك الصدوع والابتعاد عنها ان اسالك
سؤال الاخير وربما هو سؤال مليون دولار
يعني انه هل يمكن التنبؤ بامكانيه حدود
زلازل اخرى يعني الناس بعد نحو اسبوعين من
الزلزالين ماء يعني بداوا بالتقاط انفاسهم
حتى تم يعني حدوث هذين الزلزالين وبالتالي
كيف يتم التعامل هل هناك اي مؤشرات علميه
من مراكز الرصد تفيد بانه هناك امكانيه
لحدود زلزال ما
الان فيما يخص المنطقه الاولى قبل اسبوعين
يعني تقديري النشاط الزلزالي في حدود
الاربع درجات اكثر قليلا او اقل قليلا
طبعا يعني الاربع درجات يعني يعتبر شيء
فاصل يعني اقصد اقل من اربع درجات لا يؤثر
اطلاقا لا يؤثر على المباني اطلاقا الان
كلما زاد يكون التاثير قليل فبالتالي
نتحدث عن نشاط معتدل قليل في المنطقه يعني
التي ذكرت في في في في النشاط الاول لكن
نشاط الثاني يعني ما زلناه في في بدايه
هذه
العاصفه الاخرى لكن في تقدير يعني ما اذا
حدث فلن يكون اكبر من زلزال الرئيسي 6.4
وفي تقدير قد يكون اقل من سته ممكن يعني
بين ال 55 ونص طبعا في خلال ايام ثم يعود
الى النشاط المعتدل ويقل عن ذلك يعني حتى
حتى يحدث في حدود الاربعه درجات الى ان
نصل الى مرحله الشعور بالزلازل ينتهي ومن
ثم تبقى النشاط البداري يسجل فقط على
اجهزه الرصد التالي وهذا قد يستمر لعده
ايام او عده اسابيع انا اشكرك على كل هذه
المعلومات دكتور محمد القريوتي الباحث
والمختص في علم ورز الزلازل كنت معنا من
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
الله
حاضر
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من القميص لمراسل العربيه
جمعه كاش اهلا بك جمعه جمعه القامشلي يعني
بعيدا نسبيا عن مركز الزلزال لكن كيف شعر
سكان المدينه به وكيف تعاملوا هل سادت نفس
حاله الرعب التي سادت في شمال غرب سوريا
وايضا انطاكيا ام ان الوضع مختلف لديك
مساء الخير يعني انطلاقا من مدينه
ديريك مرورا بالقامشلي لوصولا الى شمال
غرب سوريا وتحديدا الارياف حلب وادلب
وصولا الى طرطوس واللاذقيه
نتحدث عن 650 كيلو متر جميع السكان في هذه
البلدات والمدن الكبيره شعرت
على درجات
متفاوته بقوه هذا الزلزال الى تركيز
الاكبر والشهور الاكبر بالزلزال كان في
ارياف حلب وادلب واضافه الى مدينتي
اللاذقيه وطرطوس وجده القريبتان من مركز
الزلزال في
عطايا التركيه يعني
الاكبر ايضا يعني حدث في
ارياف حلب وادلب تحديدا في بلدات وعلى
تارب والسلقين سجلنا انهيار حوالي سبع
المباني وتضرر
اخرى اجراء هذه المباني وحاله الهلع
والرعب التي اصابت الاهالي كان هناك حوالي
اصابه معظم الاصابات هي عباره عن كسور
وردود وحياه اغماء وايضا مشاكل في القلب
هذا سجل وفاه طفله في طرطوس توقف قلبها
بسبب حالات الرعب طبعا لا يزال القسم
الاكبر من الاهالي في الشوارع وايضا في
السيارات
التي امر اخرى الى الارياف القريبه الى
الاهل والاقارب المبيت
الليله قبل التقاط قرار بالعوده من عدمها
الى المباني جمعه اود ان اسالك يعني في
نقطه مهمه لم يتم الاشاره لها كثيرا بانه
المباني والمساكن في الارياف لم تتضرر
بنفس القدر الذي تضررت به المساكن
والمباني الجديده في المدن الى اي مدى هذا
الكلام دقيق
وما السبب
يعني بكل الاحوال المباني العموديه
المؤلفه من عدم الطوابق كانت خلال زلزال
الماضي اكثر عرضه
للانهيار او حتى الى التضرر الجزئي سواء
كان شقوق او تصدعات بينما فعلنا يعني
المنازل العربيه المؤهله من طابق واحد
كانت الاقل تضررا في جميع الجغرافيا
السوبيا ربما تحتاج الى اراء لمهندسين
مختصين لكن البعني المؤنثه مطابق واحد اقل
تضروره او حتى انهيار مباراه البيئه
المباني
العموديه المؤلفه لذلك يعني فعلا سكان
المدن الاساسيه خلال يعني الزلزال الاول
او حتى خلال الاعتدائيه التي تبيع
الزلزاله وحتى في زلزال الليله
اغلبهم كانوا يتوجهون الى
القرى بافضل اكثر في اكثر من المدير طيب
الان يعني حسب ما نتابع يعني قبل مده اكدت
اداره الكوارث بانه نحو 32 هزات اعتداديه
تم تسجيلها ربما كان العدد اكبر الى اي
مدى هذه الهزات الارتداديه عززت من مخاوف
السكان ودفعتهم للتمسك البقاء في الشارع
وعدم العوده الى منازلهم في شمال غرب
سوريا وايضا المناطق التي شعرت ايضا
بالزلزال في شمال سوريا
بالضبط يعني يعني الهزات ايضا يعني
يشعر بها سكان الشمال وايضا الساحل وايضا
حتى شمال شرق البلاد وهذا يزيد مخاوف
الاهالي من العوده الى المنازل والبقاء في
يعني مراكز اللواء المؤقته وحتى في
المدارس او الساحات المفتوحه وحتى فيها
الحدائق وحتى الدكتور في المدن المدن
الرئيسيه يعني حاله الهلع والخوف لا تزال
يعني في اغلب
البلدات والمدن والناس ان يفضلون البقاء
في الخارج على الاقل هذه العوده الى
المنازل دعنا ننتقل انا اشكرك طبعا على كل
هذه المعلومات جمع كاش دعنا ننتقل الى
انطاكيا وينضم الينا من هناك الصحفي
السوري عمر جبلاوي لو طلعنا على اخر
التطورات كيف يبدو المشهد لديك بعد ساعات
من وقوع الزلزالين عمر
مساء الخير هدوء كبير جدا في انطاكيا الان
هدوء لسيارات الاسعاف التي كانت تنقل
المصابين
من داخل احياء انطاكيا
تضرر كبير لعدد كبير من المنازل قد تهدمت
بالكامل بعد ان كانت متصدعه بالزلزال
الماضي هناك تشقق في الاراضي
الاسمنتيه داخل مدينه انطاكيا ايضا هناك
تم نجاه عائله سوريه من تحت الانقاض وتم
انتشالها بخير الحمد لله وهي على قيد
الحياه بالاضافه الى ان ايضا تم اخلاء
مشفى كمال اتاتورك في انطاكيا من المصابين
ومن المرضى ومن الجميع اثناء الزلزال ايضا
هناك
شعر بهذا الزلزال القرى القريبه جدا من
انطاك الريحانيه وبلده
جميع سكان الريحانيه الان
نجحوا الى قسم منهم الى معبر باب الهوى
وقسم ايضا باتجاه اضنه ومن ثم الى متوجهين
الى انقره
يعني رغبه بليله امنه بالاضافه الى ان
سكان بلده ايضا هم الان في العراق ويبحثون
عن خيم وعن الاماكن تؤويهم هذه الليله
كثير من الحذر كثير من الرعب في قلوب
الكثيرين وتخوف كبير لهذه الليله هل هذا
هل هذا البعض الى مساكنهم هل اطمئن البعض
ام ان الكثير من سكان انطاكيا ما زالوا في
الشوارع خصوصا ان الانباء تشير الى انه
حاله هلا كبيره زادت في المدينه والشق
الثاني من السؤال يتعلق في
البنى التحتيه الى اي مدى تضررت والى اي
مدى اعاقت ربما الوصول الى بعض المباني
هناك انباء عن مباني تهدمت تحدثت عن انقاذ
عائله سوريه باكملها من تحت الانقارب لكن
هل هناك جهود تبذل لانقاذ اخرين
نعم بالتاكيد بدايه لا يوجد اي اناس
اعادوا اي سكان عادوا الى منازلهم هناك
تحذير كامل من الدوله التركيه ولكن بالامس
الحكومه التركيه يعني اعطت تصريحات لدخول
واخلاء لمنازل داخل احياء انطاكيا وهذا
ايضا قامت الحكومه التركيه ايضا بالامس
بعمليه تفتيش واسعه على المنازل وعمليه
مسح كامل للمنازل المتضرره والتي كانت
قابله للسقوط ربما المشهد غدا سيكون مختلف
تماما ستعيد الدوله
التفتيش والمسح لهذه المنازل لتحديد ما هي
المنازل التي من الممكن ان تكون قد صار في
مره اخرى لذلك هناك اليوم كثير من المنازل
التي كانت هي علاقه قائمه المنازل التي
يتم ترميمها وليس هدمها قد هدمت اليوم
نتيجه هذا الزلزال نتحدث ايضا عن ان الناس
اليوم هناك
لا يزالون داخل مخيمات في حديقه السوريين
الحديقه العامه في وسط انطاكيا بالاضافه
الى المخيمات التي اقامتها الدوله التركيه
والمنازل المسبقه الصنع في منطقه الدفنه
هل بدا هل بدا البعض من سكان
انطاكيا بالتوجه الى هذه المخيمات والمدن
التي اقامتها الحكومه وهل هناك لديها قدره
استيعابيه على ربما استقبالها هؤلاء
هناك عده عائلات ذهبوا بالامس الى هذه
المنازل المسبقه الصنع وهذه المخيمات في
منطقه الدفنه تحديدا التي شهدت كان مركز
الزلزال فيها اليوم لم يكن هناك اتساع
ابدا لاي عائله جديده تم امتلاء
المنازل المسبقه الصنع والمخيمات بالكامل
لاعداد كبيره من الناس ولكن هناك نتحدث عن
الاف الى اليوم هم في الشوارع اليوم
الالاف اليوم نجحوا الى الشوارع من بلده
التي كانت امنه بالامس بلده الريحانيه
كانت امنه بالامس هؤلاء البلده هاتين
البلدتين
فيهم الاف من السكان هم برعب حقيقي جدا
كثير منهم نزح اليوم الى انقره تحديدا
لا يريدون
يعني عن طريق الميناء الجوي حركه الطيران
هل عادت في ولايه التايكان هناك انباء
بانه المدرج لم يتضرر هل عادت حركه
الطيران ام انها ما زالت متوقفه
نعم
المنازل التي هي غير قابله للسقوط ربما
الدوله التركيه ستمنع بالكامل الاقتراب
منها واخذ اي احتياجات منها بسبب الزلزال
الذي حصل اليوم ربما يحدث زلزال اخر يعرض
الاشخاص الذين سيدخلون الى هذه المبادئ لل
خطا شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا عمر جبلاوي
الصحفي السوري كنت معنا من انطاكيا مركز
الزلزال الذي ضرب اليوم وتسبب بانهيار عدد
من المباني وايضا حاله رعب كبيره خصوصا ان
هذا الزلزال الذي وقع بقوه 6.4 اعقبه
زلزال اخر في سمن
سمندغ على الساحل في هاتاي ايضا وتسبب في
حاله رعب كان هناك محاولات
لاخلاء الناس من المساكن وانقاذ من تضرروا
بسبب سقوط المباني هذا الزلزال تدعيه وصلت
الى شمال غرب سوريا حيث ايضا كان هناك
حاله من الهلع والخوف والتدافع تسببت في
مقتل اربعه اشخاص في طرطوس وحمام
وايضا كان هناك وفيات في تركيا ثلاثه
وفيات ومئتين وثلاثه عشر مصابا